cet article un gâteau s'il est en
rébellion l'allée de la frite est née
chiper la nuit regardez ce qui arrive à
gâteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mission à tous
à lacanau
[Applaudissements]
soit
à
je tente
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
carnival pousse pas les chercher là là
là là attendez attendez ont des raisons
de sécurité là je ne parle pas du tout
les ché on est en direct
les amours l'espère ce que j'aime et
nous on va partir sur sa tablette adam
est devenu tout à fait attention de
temps en temps parce que malik a failli
faire très mal
me suis je suis debout fut un organisme
trafic de sécurité j'avais demandé à
toutes les personnes du public et toutes
les chroniqueurs de ne pas bouger parce
que je vous dis le sol notre sol c'est
un enfer et même les cadres ne bougez
pas je me demande s est pas bouger parce
que personne ne bougeait pas s'agir d'un
petit lob s'il vous plaît énormément
bref à la fin c'est des faits qu'est ce
que c'est mais c'est quand le début
c'est à la fin de l'émission french
église aujourd'hui ne l'a même pas
nouvelle
c'est dire que ces personnes ne viennent
je veux donner aux chroniqueurs de tous
s'asseoir le plus gentiment possible
mais si la somme sera donnée à ces vous
annoncer que la glisse énormément arrêté
là et la caq six ans qui est sorti se
rappelle bien sûr j'avais encore des
choses à faire votre cinéma